Let's go next to our caller from the seven
zero five area code.
Who's calling today from seven zero five
Canada.
Actually, um, I have a conspiracy.
I have a conspiracy theory.
So what I've seen on then that Alan Dershowitz
and you got, uh, like Trump's commerce can
suck. [inaudible] even I've seen the deal.
Is there a reason anybody's ever looked into
like the whole Russian connection of his obscene
sex wringing her with underage girls was just
be so pleased.
W recruiting, um, people rush her to block
now took control because it's just like Glen's
telling me,
Steve, I have no idea what you're talking
about.
And I don't know if it's the connection or
what you're saying, but Dershowitz and Russia
a conspiracy involving Biersch Rowitz in Russia.
Well Dershowitz is involved with the Epstein.
Yes.
He was one of the guys that used to, I don't
know that, uh, I'll just use what's our name,
uh, is uh, lo Lena plain, you know, going
into his Island and without our help.
And Trump was one of, uh, one of the people
that I hung out with up scene as well.
So like I wasn't ready to start this grand
conspiracy, but I showed that all these judges,
everything that Trump has been appointed,
uh, they all have an video with them having
sex with underage girls, like William bottom
friends says maybe they've got [inaudible]
having sex.
Okay.
All right Steve, that is quite a theory.
I wouldn't be able to say anything else about
it cause I just, I just have no idea.
But let's let people simmer on that a little
bit and see, see a, if it tickles their fancy
and if, if, if that strikes anybody as a,
as a real possibility.
Okay.
That does it for today's calls.
On that note, we will take a quick break,
much more shorter
coming up.
Sorry to everybody that I did not get to,
but many more opportunities including during
our impeachment livestream.
To get on the phone with me, the David Pakma